hey everyone welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel today we will learn
about chat gbd versus Chad Sonic if
these are the type of videos you'd like
to watch then hit that like And
subscribe buttons and the bell icon to
get notified just for a quick info if
you want to upscale yourself master
artificial intelligence and machine
learning skills and learn your dream job
or growing your career then you must
start exploring simply lcode of various
EI and ml programs simply learn offers
various certification and postgraduate
programs in collaboration with some of
the world's leading universities like
Bon Purdue Caltech IIT conour and many
more through our courses you will gain
knowledge and work expertise and skills
like generative AI prompt engineering
explainable AI machine learning
algorithms and over a dozen others
that's not all you'll also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts working
on Top Tire product companies and
academic from top universities after
completing these course thousands of
Learners have transitioned into AI or ml
role as a fresher or moved on to a
higher paying job profile if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comment and
description box below and find the AI
and ml program that fits your expertise
and areas of Interest now without
further delay let's get started so as
discussed in this video we are comparing
two AI systems Chad Sonic and chat GPD
we will explore their capabilities
limitations in detail so what is chat
GPD chat GPT is a conversational AI
trained on humanik dialogue developed by
open AI chat GPT can give humanik
responses to your inputs and can help
you with tasks such as generating emails
writing blog posts creating essays and
creating codes in various software
languages chat jib has been trained with
internet data until 2021 besides it
improves Itself by analyzing the
conversations it had with its user on
the other hand when it comes to chat
Sonic chat Sonic is a conversational AI
developed using chat gbt 3.5 and chat
gbt 4 infrastructures chat Sonic can
generate text and images to create
responses based on users input chat
Sonic has been developed to produce
images rather than just text in other
words chat Sonic can also generate
images from textual inputs let's get
back to their UI and check how exactly
the respond to the questions asked so
here we have chat gbt first so chat gbd
user interface looks a little simple and
straightforward with the black color
highlight on the and a simple grayish
background for the text so here if you
can write down any of your queries your
questions and your chats to chat GPD and
it will read them and give out the
response to you and on the other hand
when it comes to chat Sonic it has a
little brighter user interface a bluish
shade of uh section for the proms and
here you have the white background for
adding your questions so before getting
started with this asking the questions
and everything let's check out the
questions limit or you know uh basically
chat GPD has a limitation for the
questions or prompts you can use on the
other hand when it comes to B and other
competitors they pretty much don't have
any limitations as such let's check
about these both first chat gbt and chat
Sonic so chat GPT questions limit
yeah so there is a 20 to 30 question per
hour limit and also uh you can go up
with around not per hour per
day yeah so when it goes per day you
have about 50 questions of limit within
a 4our time frame and when we replace
chat gbd with chat Sonic and check out
what's the limit for
that here we
go so it's a little complicated it's not
giving the correct or exact numbers but
it says chat Sonic offers a free plan
with limited features and a 10,000 word
limit monthly this is not for daily it's
monthly and they also provide a small
team plan starting at $19 per month and
let's check the subscription for chat
GPT
so it's pretty much the same it has $20
per month and uh the chat Sonic goes
with $9 per month so yeah pretty much
now let's get back to their UI and try
to ask some questions
so hi chat
Sonic so I'm trying to write down an
email to my client to push the deadline
by week let's see how it writes it down
let's also expect it to write the
subject it is giving some proper reasons
it says th testing and quality assurance
so it might need some time ensuring that
the final deliverable exceeds your
expectation that's pretty much
convincing now let's try the same query
with chat GP
nice so chat gbt is pretty much trying
to live in the current situation which
might be more convincing here it says we
are trying to address some of the
additional unfor issues so this might
take a while and yeah we understand the
importance this is nice and pretty much
good but it's not as convincing as chat
Sonic so it said that your product might
be highly uh better than expected so
that's that was a little highlighted
point there so in here you can see the
better highlighted point is about the UN
forcing situations so it is trying to
live practical here so it's good it's
not just giving some uh sugar coating to
the client so it's pretty decent now uh
let's try to book some
tickets
hotel
reservation sorry so it cannot U book
you any sorts of hotal reservations or
tickets but if I ask the same question
to chat Sonic let's see what it replies
ideally it should not because uh it
should not have access to any of my
credentials so it should say I can't but
let's see what it throws it is taking a
little while I might expect some good
results okay I'm sorry I don't have the
capability but again when you compare
the same with other competitors like b
or any other they end up giving you some
Alternatives exactly they will say I'm
sorry I can't but they give some
alternate results like a link to a hotel
booking website or some suggestions
which is the best uh hotel or they might
even ask you questions where do you
exactly want to go I might help you to
get some good places around or I might
help you to get some good uh locations
around so as far as chat Sonic and chat
jpd are concerned both are on the same
page and uh another major difference
about these both is how updated are they
so if I ask some latest questions about
uh the current year updates to chat
Sonic let's see what it yields in let's
say
um what's
the
result of
Cricket World
Cup
scrolling result let's see ideally when
I see a question with e numbers I am
having the database up to 2021 or
something and it might not give me a
right result but again let's check
Australia emerged here that's the right
answer but when I ask the same questions
to chat GPD let's see what it has to say
ideally it should give an answer but
again uh since the number 2003 or year
number 2003 is included I am presuming
that it might say I have the data
updated till
2021 let's see I'm sorry yeah exactly
what I expected so these are the pretty
much differences what you have on both
chat GPD
and chat Sonic and when it comes to um
the specifications we know uh chat Sonic
is basically based on the Frameworks of
chat jbt 3.5 and J 3. yeah 3.5 and chart
gbt 4 so there shouldn't be much of a
difference between both of the
Frameworks so yeah this is how both of
them respond so with this we have come
to end of the session on chat GPD versus
chat Sonic and if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
this session then please feel free to
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts we'll be happy
to help you as soon as possible until
next time thank you for watching and
stay tuned for more from Simply done
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos Ed up and get certified click
here